you were convicted of 39 felonies for
cyber crime
placed on the us most wanted list in
2006
escaped from prison
you built the first organized cyber
crime community called shadow crew that
is the precursor to today's dark net and
darknet markets and
for all this the us intelligence service
called you the original internet
godfather
so first question how did your career
as a cyber crime criminal begin my life
of crime begins when i'm 10 years old
10 years old man think about that i mean
i you were probably playing the robots
when you were 10. you know usually kids
are doing a lego bit getting involved
with sports everything else and
with me it wasn't like that with me i'm
from eastern kentucky eastern kentucky
is one of these
it's like parts of texas parts of
louisiana that if you're not fortunate
enough have a job you may be involved in
a scam hustle fraud whatever you want to
call it man i was
my parents
my mom was basically the captain of the
entire fraud industry so this is a this
is a woman that at one point she's
stealing a 108 000 pound caterpillar d9
bulldozer tramming it down the road you
know at another point she's taking a
slip and phone a convenience store
trying to sue the owner
we had a neighbor she acted as a pimp
for at one point that's my mom uh my dad
wait wait
the neighbor acted as a pimp my mom
prostituted i mean she she acted as a
pimp for a neighbor
her name was debbie and
my mom used to sell her out you know
debbie needed money and my mom would
find men for her to sleep with for cash
and she'd take a part of the cash so it
sounds like she diversified the
methodologies
by which she uh hustled very
had that entrepreneurial spirit okay you
know
we see that a lot with uh with cyber
criminals you know that uh that sense of
being that entrepreneur so what was the
motivation you think for her
is it uh
is it money
is it basically the uh the rush of
playing with the system of being able to
um
know the rules and break the rules and
get away with it my mom's a complex
character she is there's no one single
motivation so my mom was the individual
she's still alive
my mom was the individual who
tested people
she wanted to know how far she could
abuse you and you come back and still
love her so and that was with every
relationship she's ever had
she would cheat on the men she was
involved with she would abuse the uh her
children me and denise she would uh
psychological physical oh it was mental
emotional
physical
um everything everything i mean she uh
she used to beat me and denise with uh
with belt buckles you know and that
ended
when uh
she was i forgot what we had done
it wasn't much i think that uh
um
it may have been the part where she she
accused me of stealing her marijuana
but uh she was hitting me and denise we
were living in a single wide trailer at
that point
she was hitting me and denise we were we
were on the bed trying to get away from
it and denise
kicks her through a closet
is what happens and
denise stands up and she said
you're through hitting me
and that was the last time that mom hit
us at that point
but uh so sorry to take us there you're
for people who know you and people
should definitely watch some of your
lectures online you're extremely
charismatic and fun and
uh
jolly and whatever word you want to use
but you know if we look at that kind of
life it's there's darkness there there's
a struggle there
there's a lot of darkness so
if you if you how did you feel if you go
back to the mind of the kid you were
with your mom was um
was there sadness was there things like
depression
self-doubt all those kinds of things or
did you see this crime this chaos
is ultimately exciting you know i don't
think
back then i didn't view it as exciting
now it becomes exciting when i started
being involved in cyber cyber crime all
right but back then it was simply a
means to an end was all it was so you
take a 10 year old kid and the way i get
involved in crime
is like i said my mom was the fraudster
my dad was my dad was a good guy he just
forgot he was this good guy you know he
was always he always had these
principles but his issue was
is he loved my mom so much he was scared
of of her leaving
so if she wanted to do something commit
crime cheat on him
whatever
he would pretty much just put up with it
um the the one instant so i mean this
woman used to she used to bring men home
in front of him
tell him that hey i'm leaving you i
don't love you anymore i want you to die
blah blah blah blah blah this was my mom
there were two instances where the man
where he can't take it anymore
and the first instance i was i guess i
was seven or eight my sister denise is a
year younger than i am my dad actually
files for divorce
files for divorce at that point my mom
kind of goes crazy
uh my dad i was with my dad my sister
was with my mother because that's that
eastern kentucky mentality you know men
stay with men women stay with women so
he was filing for divorce me and my dad
we were living in an apartment
my mom was living with
with her grandparents and with her
parents bouncing back and forth between
the two
and i remember i was sleeping in the bed
we had a single wide bed my dad slept on
on the sofa
i woke up one night and there was some
sort of ruckus in the living room
so i wake up and i walk into the living
room and my mom has a knife to my dad's
throat
and basically you're not going to steal
my son from me
my mom was this individual
that
when she knew she went so far like i
said she was always this person that
tested well can i do this to you and
you'll still come back
she knew
she she was always also this person that
if she went too far
she knew it and she would always try to
divert that into something else alright
so she knew at that point she went too
far so what does she do she gets up
crying
goes to the bathroom and pretends to
slit her wrists
so that my dad ray will respond to that
not respond to what she's just done to
him that was my mom in a nutshell and
she had a history of doing this kind of
stuff um
motivations as far as fraud with her
i think with her it was
she was an lpn she had a very good nurse
but she didn't want to work
was a lot of it so so with her it was
easier for her
to commit fraud and when i say commit
fraud it was against businesses against
people i remember at one point she's uh
she's buying over-the-counter capsules
and emptying the capsules out putting
some other crap in there in there and
selling at a speed and people are buying
it
she did anything she could for money and
of course i get involved with that what
happens is is
my we were in east we were in panama
city at that point and uh
my mom leaves my dad
and the way she left my dad
my great-grandfather had died
my mom tells all three of us hey i'm
we're going i'm taking the kids and
we're going back to eastern kentucky to
attend the funeral
well
that was her leaving
me and denise didn't know she didn't
pack any of our clothes at all she stows
her clothes in the trunk of the of the
car
and she leaves my dad and i don't get to
see my dad again for i think five six
years something like that
my mom like i said she used to bring men
home in front of my dad
she would
he'd sit there and cry and beg her not
to do it she'd do it anyway when she
leaves them
she kept up that
so we were we were living at my
grandparents house my grandfather he had
converted the house he had raised the
house up and built apartments underneath
of it
so me and my sister and my mom lived in
one of the apartments underneath and uh
that whole sound of the family was just
nuts was nuts my granddad paul
he would
this this is a man that
he didn't want you to eat any of his
food
so you know there was no such thing as
me and denise going upstairs to eat
if he found out me and denise was taking
a bath
we were allowed to bath and bathe in two
inches of water
one time a week because he didn't want
to have to pay the water bill this rules
the rules you know if you couldn't have
the tv on
when he went to bed at night you had to
have the television the volume you could
watch it but without volume because if
he heard it he would he would get up in
the middle of the night and he would
kick the power breaker turn off all the
power on you this is my this is my the
family right so my mom
she used to leave me and denise at home
for uh for days man for days she'd go
out and you know party
and uh
i mean sometimes she'd take me a nice
wither we'd wait in the car
sometimes we'd uh wait in the living
room and she went and partied and
everything else
most times she left left us at home and
my entry into crime
denise walks in one day she's she's nine
years old man she walks in one day and
she's got a pack of pork chops in her
hand
and
looked at her and i said where'd you get
that she's like i stole it
and
you know it's like show me how you did
that so she takes me over and she shows
me how she steals food how she's
stuffing it down her pants
so we start stealing food i'm like hell
yeah let's do that [ __ ] so start
stealing food and we get to the point
where we're wanting a sandwich
well you can't stuff a loaf of bread
down your pants
so there was a kmart in the shopping
center i go over to the kmart
get a hoodie off the off the rack take
the tags off of it wear it out work just
fine and the way you steal bread is you
put the hoodie over your shoulder stuff
the loaf of bread down the sleeve and
you walk out with it so we started doing
that how'd you figure that out
just thought pattern so you so there's
there's like
strategic
thinking here yeah you know you can't
wear the hoodie and put the bread down
here because you might mash the bread
when you zip it up or yeah we have to
think through that you got to think
through it but but you got to realize
about by this point i'm helping i'm
already seeing what my parents are doing
you know i'm already saying this just to
see that plotting that kind of puzzle
solving was something you're already
developing oh yeah individually you're
pretty young yeah 10 years old pretty
young but but seeing how they act how
they respond to things and and
my mom i guess you call it a good thing
she they never kept any of that hidden
from the kids yeah you know there was no
no discussions behind closed doors all
that happened in front of everybody and
from your young mind's perspective
seeing that kind of crime
you basically you know a lot of us kind
of grow up thinking there's rules you're
not supposed to break if you see other
humans breaking those rules then though
you realize those rules are just
human-made but it gets worse than that
you i was in an environment where
there were no decent people
i didn't really meet my first decent
person until i was 16 years old
who's that that was a high school
teacher so what happens is
you know we start shoplifting food my
mom finds out that we've been stealing
stuff and you know she joins us
what's that she joins us
yeah she comes in you know i've got the
television i've got the atari 2600 play
the hell out of it oh my gosh she starts
seeing this [ __ ] she's like where'd this
come from and i'm like well we found it
she's like he didn't find that denise
denise stands up we stole it
my mom
showed me how you did that
and she gets her mom too to join in and
she used to run me and denise's these
little shoplifters we'd take
you know we'd steal stuff for her we
would distract security
and her and my grandmother would steal
stuff
they got caught doing that
but that's that's the entry into crime
and denise you know i'm i'm adamant and
i
i kind of mean it
but
the the truth is i say and i i do i do
mean it that i'm responsible for my
choices as an adult
all right i believe that when you're a
child you can't control that the adults
in your environment control what you do
all right once you're an adult though
your choices are yours now that being
said
there's some
you can't dismiss that childhood
influencing what i did as an adult
you can't do that i mean it was kind of
written on on slate that hey this guy's
going to be this guy when he grows up
that said like sometimes that one person
you meet that decent person can turn the
tide absolutely absolutely so what
happens is you know the abuse everything
continues on
when i'm 15.
my dad was in uh was in panama city
florida my mom was in uh you know we
were in hazard kentucky
she uh
she was dating this guy she and my mom
was this woman that uh
the abuse would it was it was crazy
abuse man just crazy stuff you she would
tell me and my sister you know that uh
she gave up her life for us that she was
gonna leave one day and never come back
that we'd find her dead in a ditch
someplace she'd go out and date these
men and she'd come back and she'd talk
about how these men
were abusing her
you know so she'd be dating this guy
and uh
she'd come back and then she'd you know
start talking about how he had tried to
rape her you know trying to get me to
respond to that and i would respond to
that make no doubt i would respond to
that
well what happens is and i knew that
i don't know if i knew it was abuse at
that age all right but i knew things
were [ __ ] up
and
i was talking to my dad in panama city
and i really had it in my head that
that i was going to go down and live
with my dad
and
i called my dad one day
i was set to go to uh me and my cousins
were going to go see uh return of the
jedi that it came out again in the
theaters
so i called my dad it was a sunday
called my dad and he told me
he had either gotten married or he was
about to get married to this woman and
basically brett johnson wasn't going to
go down to florida you know i was going
i was going to stay in hazard
i had to call my dad from payphone but
the result of that was i walked into a
into a hospital
got in an elevator
and a woman got an elevator at the same
time and i snapped and beat the hell out
of her
right there
and i was 15.
didn't really know what the [ __ ]
happened
didn't really know but uh just anger
came from somewhere yeah yeah
and uh
you know the uh they'll beat the hell
out of this lady
turned out she looked a shitload like my
mom
but
the elevator doors open
one of the security guards i played
basketball with his son so he didn't he
saw me immediately i knocked the hell
out of him took off running
made it back to the house where my
granddad grandparents were they didn't
know what had happened so
i didn't say anything
about an hour later kentucky state
police they pull up in the front yard
and uh two of them get out and i'm
sitting on the front porch and me and my
cousins are and
they start walking up where everybody
starts walking out of the house and i'm
like i just remember saying what do you
want what do you want well you know what
they wanted they wanted
to arrest brett johnson and then they
arrested me i went in i told them
everything
um
spent three months in a county jail they
didn't have
juvenile facilities
in that county so i spent three months
in solitary
went to trial
pled guilty to assault and first degree
the the judge
sentenced me to time served in a
psychological evaluation where they sent
me to louisville kentucky
and spent 30 days up there they cut me
loose they wanted me to
have counseling after that
and uh
never went to counseling you know i
wanted to but mom was like don't need it
and
so never went to counseling and
i became this pariah
in the county uh
it's crazy man i i mean uh
not a day goes by that i don't think
about that
that that moment in the elevator yeah
and and what happens is is uh
you know you're 15. [ __ ] man you're 15.
so i go back to the uh the high school
that i was in
and um
i'm this piece of [ __ ]
to everybody
everybody
everybody knows
so i moved we moved we were we were in
whitesburg at that point
i finished up the year there
and moved to uh back to perry county
where which is where hazard is
so we moved there and they've got three
high schools here they've got m.c napier
they've got hazard high school and then
they've got dills combs high school
so
i was within mandanese were within
a half mile of m.c napier
show up there the first day of school
and i met uh me and my mom and my sister
were walking into the school
and the kids won't let me in
the kids
stand out there he's not coming in
so uh
my mom starts raising help and i'm like
nah let's just go let's go so from there
it was uh we went down to the city
school hazard
and the principal tells my mom
denise can come
he can't so uh
my mom wants to raise her and i'm like
no let's just uh just take me to this
other school so this other school was
like 15 miles away
and uh
you know country country school country
high school
so i go there and they accept me and i
walked in the first day
and uh
this english teacher
name's carol combs
i walked in and uh
handed her the paper out she was my home
room teacher
and
she heard this voice as the way she
explains it to me she heard this voice
and she looks up and she was like
son have you ever done any drama before
i'm like
no ma'am but i'm interested in the
academic team i was this quick recall
guy right
and she's like no she's like
drama
i'm like no i'm not interested in
theater i'm interested in academics well
she was the head of the drama department
and head of the academics department so
the deal was
tell you what you can get on the
academics team if
you start with theater too and i was
like okay
so uh what happens is she was the only
she was the first decent person i met in
my life and she became this kind of
surrogate mother to me
so under her tutelage i've become the uh
one of the top academic team guys in the
state
around i was captain of the team i was
this this just just scourge across all
the counties in that part of kentucky if
you know we had a had a meet it was like
jesus christ that's brett johnson
you know it was like
she used to tell people they would
the the high school that i came from was
whitesburg and the first time that
weisberg came against us
she she told me i was talking to her
about a year ago and she told me she's
like brett she said that first meet
against twiceberg
she said
the captain came in looked at you
and said oh you've got that johnson boy
on your team and she said my response
was that johnson boy is our team
[Laughter]
so
but i did that and then with with
theater i ended up my senior year i won
best actor and actress in the state the
only guy i'd ever do that in the state
so um
did pretty well man did pretty well had
had scholarships coming out out of high
school and everything else and i'm the
idiot that turned him down ask you a
funny question yeah
you'd make a hell of a i mean of all the
many things you could probably do you
make a hell of a
actor i'm very good on stage i'm very
good on stage have you acted
professionally anywhere or not not not
professionally we've done the you know
the college circuit and stuff like that
what happened was is uh
so i turned down the um
turned down the scholarships you know
scared of leaving i guess is what it was
start starting community college
and
the community college there hires a new
theater director out of california well
he knew the guy
that ran the san jose state theater
program a guy named edward emanuel was
his name his claim to fame he had
written the three ninjas movie remember
that the three little ninja kids back in
the 80s he had written this for damn
film and it made a shitload of money
so he invites ed emanuel to come down
and see the play and ed had written this
civil war piece
so we put that on
i was doing like it was a multiple role
thing i was doing like 18 different
roles in the show
so ed sees the show and he's like
scholarship he said look he said right
now you're a big fish in a small pond
we'll make you a big fish in a big pot
and i was like deal so i took the
scholarship man and he was like i'll be
back in two weeks so he flies out two
weeks later this guy flies back in he
drives down to where where i'm living
i'm out shooting ball with with my
cousins and friends
he pulls up
and he gets out of the car and i was
like um walk over to him i was like hey
man i'll
walk in you can meet my parents he's
like no i got it i was like okay so i
keep shooting ball he walks in the house
stays about 15 minutes
walks out white as a sheet
doesn't say word to me
gets in the car
leaves
i don't hear from him again
had no idea what went on
it takes me a couple weeks what happened
is my mom he walks in and introduces
himself
my mom pulls a knife on the guy
i will kill you you are not going to
steal my goddamn son from me
scares the guy to death he bugs out and
kind of broke my spirit at that point
you know i was like
okay
so
went into just full-fledged into
scams crimes everything else i had
already been when i was a minor
i'd already been kind of brought up on
that side of the family with the crimes
that they were doing my mom was you know
drug trafficking the pimp stuff
illegally mining coal
charity fraud illegally mining yeah
wildcatting coal so you um can you
explain that yeah so
to to properly mine coal you have to get
a permit all right
eastern kentucky a lot of people don't
they can't afford the permits you know
they can they can get them a piece of
equipment uh you know you get a dozen a
loader or whatever you're gonna get or
an auger or what have you so you start
mining but you don't get the permit so
you don't have to find do the you don't
have to pay back then it was like thirty
five hundred dollars for a two acre
perimeter five thousand dollars for a
two acre per minute let you strip mine
the the coal on that then you have to
pay for the reclamation on top of that
so once you uncover the pit take the
coal out you have to cover back up the
pit
sow grass make sure everything is
environmentally friendly you got a silt
pond everything else at that point so
the whole idea is you buy an acre of
land or some area of land and then you
can there's a whole process you're
supposed to go through the entire
process how many people involved in a
mining the smallest number of people
required for mining operations you can
do with three or four people okay so
you've got your loader operator you've
got your dozer operator you need uh you
can you can farm out the trucking to
someone if you need that or trucking
company if you need to do that
um then you've got your whoever owns the
business as well so very few people can
run
an operation like that and profit fairly
well as long as
you don't have to do the reclamation all
that crap on top of it all right the
reclamation gets pretty expensive so if
you're uncovering a pit of coal
you know
a pit so a ton of coal is basically
about 36 cubic inches that's what what a
2 000 pounds of coal weighs if you're in
eastern kentucky because it's that the
weight of the bituminous coal and
everything the fact that you know this
is awesome
the fact that you know
exactly
the volume of a ton of cult i mean
yeah you learn this [ __ ] right you
rattle this [ __ ] off so uh so you
uncover the pit and you've got to sell
the pit well the thing is is that where
are you going to sell the coal well you
sell it to one of these other coal
tipples that knows that they're buying
the [ __ ] illegally so back then a ton of
coal was they'd give you like 36 bucks
per ton is what that is and you'd have
to go out and you'd test the btus on it
you take a sample to the lab test the
btus you take that into the company uh
british thermal unit so you'd test how
what the btu on the coal was how bad
here are the coal how pure the coal is
what what what btu it burns at back then
a good a good btu was around twelve nine
was what you'd get all right so twelve
nine coal 36 dollars a ton you'd take
that sample over to the into the cold
tipple they'd say okay we'll buy this
for you how many trucks you got or how
many tons you got and you say this is
what what we've got then you'd hire the
trucking company and where you get it
out because you know you've got the
agents that are that are looking for you
by this point because the people that
you know you've you've bought the rights
to whoever the landowner is you said
you're going to give them you know two
dollars a ton or whatever this is
well the other people there are you
paying them off
or are you not well if you're not paying
them off guess what they know your ass
is mining it illegally they're going to
report you well all of a sudden you've
got all these inspectors that are coming
around and everything and hey we know
what you're doing so they're looking for
you to get the pit out so when do you
get the pit out right in the dead of
night so you know you're loading it up
two o'clock in the morning hauling this
ass out is what you're doing you sell it
out from there so um and your mom ran
operations like this
yeah and you said you worked the mine
too yeah younger learned how to run a
loader run a dozer learned how to clean
off a pit
everything like that
so this is this is the lifestyle you you
grow up in you know you learn how to do
this stuff and uh
so knew how to do charity fraud as well
uh insurance fraud so charity fraud can
we can we break down some some of these
are charity fraud it's it's much more
romantic than what it sounds it was
basically
it was basically standing beside the
road with a sign and a bucket yeah
taking up collections for homeless
shelters for abused women for children
stuff like that um then later on i
branched off
when i started off on my own i would set
up my own charity company
and do some telemarketing and go on by
and collect checks and things like that
you know we're going to talk about that
but actually can we just step back and
talk about your mom and your dad
given all of that
given all the abuse
the complex ways that she played with
love
to see how far she can push you and the
people around her and they still love
her
today do you love her
you know i called my dad yesterday uh my
dad he's uh he's dying now he's got a
heart condition he's not gonna get the
operation to fix it so he's like [ __ ] it
i'm ready to go and i'm like i looked
down because hell i'm 52 now
prior to 52 i'd have been like no you
need to do this but i looked at him and
i was like
i understand i understand you're done
and
so he's not going to get the operation i
was talking to him yesterday he asked me
he's like have you seen your mom and i
was like dad i've not talked to her for
about two years
and uh i told him i was like
i love my mom
but my mom is not a good person
she's not and uh he told me i was
talking to him on the phone yesterday
and he told me that it took him several
years
to really understand that you know he
loved her too
but it takes when you're when you're
getting abused like that especially my
dad my dad came from a good family
everything else and
you know upstanding family and
i think that when you're that victim of
abuse
you know you've never seen it before
you've never encountered it and then it
happens
well you're like that frog in water all
of a sudden you know you get to the
point where
gradually increases until how do you get
out of it everybody else sees what's
happening but you don't
i grew up in that environment though you
know so it took me a long time
to
to come to terms with that my sister
came to terms with it long before i did
you know my sister she she's been a
decade without talking to my mom
like she had tried to commit suicide i
didn't know that what got me so bad
is she said at one point
that she always thought
someone was going to come in and save us
and my response just immediate response
not even thinking about it my response
was well denise i knew no one ever was
and
looking at things now
i think that's the that's where our
paths diverged
me it was
if you want to do it
if anybody's going to take care of you
you got to take care of yourself you're
on your own you're on your own
you know it's up to you
and denise has always been that that
child
that has expected someone to come in and
save her
well and almost like it's all going to
be okay somebody yeah and i knew it
wasn't
no no unless you
unless you make it okay it ain't going
to be okay
so
you know
are you able to
forgive
her your mom
my my boundary with my mom the reason
i've not spoken with her
over two years ago i started
this this legal career of mine
i've been the guy who has
i spent a lot of time
thinking about my past and those choices
and what brought brought those choices
around so i'm big about taking
responsibility for my actions i truly am
i think it's really important you have
to do that
well my mom
not so much
so i was talking to her you know and i
would start saying you know she was
she would start the conversation talking
about she didn't understand why denise
wouldn't speak to her anymore that was
one of her tropes
so and my response started to become
well because you were the abuser
and you spent your life doing that to
her so it's more healthy for her not to
talk to you so she's still not able to
see the flaws and and oh no her ways of
the past no not at all so my my
ultimatum to my mom was look when you're
able to admit that you abuse the people
in your life
accept that responsibility and be able
to discuss it with me
we'll have a talk other than that i
don't want to talk to you anymore so for
the first year it was you know calling
cussing my wife out cussing me out um
you know i don't need you blah blah blah
blah blah and then finally it started to
taper off and she's never
really contacted me after that point
your dad
is dying
what do you take from the way he's taken
on death just saying [ __ ] it you know
it's
the man
and what have you learned from your dad
what do you love about your dad he's one
of these guys that uh you know like i
told him
i told my dad about the about the abuse
and everything else and there was a
point so you know i told you about the
elevator stuff but before that man it
was
it took me 40 years to talk about that
but it also took me 40 years
to
to talk about there was a point
that
my mom and dad would leave the house
and i would urinate in the floor
all right and uh
there's a like
out of anger
no idea why all right but i would piss
on the carpet carpet pistors like the
lebowski right
[Laughter]
that really tied the room together they
really tied the room together i was
talking about that this lady comes up to
me after the uh after the presentation
and she had she had a career previous to
that where she dealt with abused kids
and she told me she's like brett she's
like
it's a control mechanism
the only control you had was that and
she's like kids do that
and i was like so i'm not unique she's
like no you're not unique in that
so um
that you know this whole history of
abuse denise dealt with it by drinking
by trying to commit suicide
things like that and then finally she
escapes i'm the kid that didn't and not
only that my wife pointed out to me that
it's against that eastern kentucky
mentality stuff you know the male is
expected to do things so with with me it
was it was almost like i stepped up
to to take part in those crimes so that
denise didn't didn't have to and she was
able to avoid all that other than that
one shoplifting stuff denise doesn't
break the law anymore she goes off to be
a
she's a she's a good parent she's an
angry parent she's a good parent she's a
teacher
good citizen overall i was just the guy
that kept right on going with it
you